en apoyo al ejército y al gobierno
etíope miles de personas salieron a las
calles de la capital addis abeba para
circular a las fuerzas oficiales
rechazar la alianza de fuerzas rebeldes
de tigre que amenazan con avanzar hacia
la ciudad
marchemos al frente debemos tomar la
decisión ahora de luchar por la
independencia de nuestro país tenemos
que garantizar la paz de nuestra ciudad
tenemos que bloquear la vía de entrada y
salida a las fuerzas de distracción y
sofocar los
desde hace cinco días el país está en
estado de emergencia debido a la
intensificación del conflicto en la
norteña región de tigre que ya entró en
su primer año y deja miles de muertos y
más de dos millones de desplazados
internos los manifestantes portaban
enormes pancartas con eslóganes que
criticaban la cobertura de los medios de
comunicación occidentales sobre etiopía
otros mostraron su enfado por el
llamamiento de washington para que el
gobierno federal y el frente de
liberación popular de tigre inicien
conversaciones
de no más negociación porque el gobierno
de eeuu no negocia con terroristas como
al shabab quieren destruir nuestro país
como hicieron en afganistán nunca lo
conseguirán nada
la razón por la que estoy aquí hoy es en
primer lugar para ganancia la invasión
del enemigo en mi país en segundo lugar
para venirme al ejército
el sábado el consejo de seguridad de
naciones unidas emitió un comunicado
respaldado por 15 países en el que
responsabiliza de graves crímenes y
abusos de derechos humanos a todas las
partes que luchan en el conflicto etíope